Director Matt Reeves ditches a traditional
origin story for his latest movie, "The Batman."
Instead, the 2022 film begins with Bruce Wayne
well into his second year of vigilante work
in Gotham City.
He's a brutal force on the streets as he breezes
through fights with thugs and seasoned gangsters
alike to protect the innocent — although
he's definitely still a little rough around
the edges.
Regular citizens aren't sure whether the Dark
Knight is a hero or a monster, and he still
has an incredibly uneasy relationship with
the Gotham City Police Department despite
the unquestioning trust Jim Gordon places
in him.
Things in Gotham go from bad to worse when
the Riddler rears his ugly, mask-covered mug
to target institutional corruption in Gotham.
He starts with the mayor.
From there, Batman and Selina Kyle, aka Catwoman,
try to figure out why the Riddler is hell-bent
on tearing the city down.
Unfortunately, that isn't so easy when the
killer's mysterious game is built upon riddles,
mind-bending mysteries, and a criminal conspiracy.
The early reception to the movie has been
incredibly positive, and as of this video
it currently has an 86% critic score on Rotten
Tomatoes, with WhatToWatch saying it, quote,
"fires on all cylinders."
But, like every good comic book movie, "The
Batman" ends with a dramatic fight to save
the day.
It's time to look at the hero's tactics in
the Gotham Arena brawl.
Careful, spoilers ahead!
The Riddler's plan to destroy Gotham's infrastructure
culminates with the detonation of seven bombs
around the city's sea wall, flooding the downtown
area.
Thousands of Gotham citizens congregating
downtown to celebrate Bella Real's mayoral
win rush to the Gotham Arena to escape the
high waters.
As they seek safety, a gang of Riddler's followers,
all dressed in matching uniforms, open fire
from rigging high above the arena.
Thankfully, Batman and Catwoman are on the
scene to take them down and save the people
down below, but the Caped Crusader might have
broken his rule against killing in the midst
of fighting back.
Historically, whether it's in film, TV, comics,
or video games, Batman always makes a point
that he doesn't kill criminals.
This rule stems from the trauma of watching
his parents die that night in Crime Alley.
However, during "The Batman" finale, as the
gunmen working for Riddler take shots at Batman
at close range, he deflects the bullets back
at the shooters, which sends a few of them
slumping to the floor.
It's not clear if their wounds are fatal,
but it doesn't exactly look good.
Obviously, there's the suspension of disbelief
here.
The audience doesn't see Batman kill anyone,
nor do we see the Riddler's gunmen die in
the fight.
Even the lone goon he nearly beats to a pulp
is saved when Jim Gordon intervenes.
As such, it's easy to assume that Batman stuck
to his one rule.
But, in this grim and gritty world that Matt
Reeves has created, it wouldn't be a stretch
to think that if they died because of the
fight, Batman wouldn't be too bothered by
it.
Because the film ends on a surprisingly hopeful
note, maybe the Bat will have a different
outlook when it comes to brutalizing his foes
from now on.
In the last decade or so, the debate over
whether Batman inadvertently kills people
has become a hot-button topic — even hitting
a fever pitch with the Dark Knight's actions
in "Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice."
Zack Snyder's second movie in the DC Extended
Universe sees Ben Affleck's hero dish out
some brutal punishment to Lex Luthor's goons
across the film.
Whether it's his chaotic car chase through
Gotham Harbor or that savage warehouse fight,
the older version of the Dark Knight doesn't
pull his punches at all.
Realistically, it's all about the story that
Batman happens to be in at the time.
The "no killing" rule can be pushed or broken
depending on which director or author is controlling
Batman's story.
With the Robert Pattinson-led "The Batman,"
it's clear that this version of the hero is
still questioning his approach to fighting
crime; even he acknowledges he needs to be
a better symbol to the people of Gotham.
So, although he's not too bothered by deflecting
bullets back at his foes, he is at least trying
to be better.
Obviously, there's an argument to be made
that Bruce Wayne isn't actively trying to
kill the Riddler's followers while in Batman
mode; he's just defending himself.
In the most idealized versions of the character,
like "Batman: The Animated Series," the specifics
about his "no killing" rule definitely matter.
But when the story is directly analyzing who
Batman is and how he's growing as a hero,
there's a little bit of breathing room when
it comes to his violent streak.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.